bonjour patrice bonjour patrice je suis
ravi de rencontrer ici on est au théâtre
montansier 1 aura lieu le gala du
festival de rock au cours dont vous êtes
le président messieurs il ravi qu'on se
rencontre dans un théâtre parce qu'au
fond c'est votre lieu de prédilection
théâtre à la salle a toujours été dès le
début de début d'abord j'ai vécu
exactement à 100 mètres d'ici l'été je
vivais entre 13 et 16 ans ici là haut
cadre des rares donc j'étais tout le
temps fourré noté dans ses autres et
puis c'est le début de ma carrière c'est
ce que j'avais choisi puis la télé main
peu ap c'est parce que les gens vous
connaissent évidemment par la télévision
les chiffres et les lettres fort boyard
a mis le der amis de même le poker quand
même le poc mémé votre vraie passion et
votre vraie vocation
d'ailleurs vous commencé au début il ya
veillé mais vous étiez avec michel
sardou et michel fugain et sardou qui
voulait pas faire de la chanson qui
voudrait faire du comédien elle vous et
studio 6 et filion aussi et on s'est
rencontré au cours des furets au furet
m'a dit prends ces petits jeunes
essayent de l'est parce que moi j'étais
un peu à l'époque plus un peu plus âgés
que sa vedette de cours qui m'avait dit
tu prends tu prends ces deux petits
jeunes ont en main pour le remonter une
semaine puis sow s'est très vite arrêté
et finalement se retrouver tous les
trois glands des dons des chansons et a
écrit des chansons parce que michel à
divo finalement moi je vais chanter
fugard disent tu veux j'ai des musiques
et on n'a pas de parole et aubin moi je
vais me mettre à écrire
on a fait plus effet les dix premières
chansons sardou s'est mobilisée comme ça
marchait pas pour lui après des qui m'a
quitté sedan c'est bizarre mais c'est
vrai et puis bon donc y eut le théâtre
il ya eu des films il ya le premier
passait pas le premier mais notent des
provinces et les gendarmes à saint
tropez vous êtes en effet avant le drame
centre gauche était le gendre de funès
de finesse où j'ai poussé sa fille ce
qui me disait à la fin je me disais mais
je vais du fait puisque j'ai épousé sa
fille et qu'elle reste dans les autres
films je vais tout le temps là et non
ils ont éliminé on à bercy on avait du
livre ses produits on peut le dire la
voix the rheumatic non mais je jouais
aussi à l'époque on jouait très
primesautier jolie bimbo et puis après
il ya en europe un journaliste et armand
jammot qui vous a pris beaucoup de fans
ont ils étaient copains et mon père
pourrait franchement cette opération de
l'histoire en à fond et qui a eu l'idée
ballan contreuse de faire dans sa maison
d'édition disons un secteur de jeu de
société qui était un échec complet
il est brillamment jamot pourront mettre
le directeur et puis en bon chef du
contrat avec lui comme coach breton
parlé comme ça je mentais sinon vous le
ferez aujourd'hui madame c'est une et en
faire un stage et puis c'est parti
ouais je peux vous dire que les
désaccords je vais pas cracher là dessus
j'ai fait une carrière honorable mais
j'ai mon mac ont tonné dans le jeu comme
les jeux je faisais au marché ou parce
que j'avais du pif ou parce que j'étais
pas trop mauvais à chaque fois qu'ils
avaient un nouveau jeu qu laquelle elle
s'était pas patrice adoption aurait rêvé
de faire du tokyo peut plus sérieuse un
peu plus creusé mais j'ai fait
l'émission le pmi chez mes raisons
raison de sa rémission de société très
bien ça m'a passionné c'était ma
meilleure et promettent qu'ils avaient
péché d être allé j'ai découvert
promesses les frères bogdanoff bougrain
dubourg bouger de ce bon état et plein
d'autres mais j'étais un préquel c'est
bien des liens il avait raison c'était
une émission intéressante peut-être un
peu avant 60 ans mais c'est vrai c'est
le drame affreux et voilà c'est de faire
des succès et voilà autant de verbes
beaux jours de poche non non non c'est
vachement bien et puis j'ai eu comme les
gens qui me disent maintenant mais
comment ça se soit pas encore à la
retraite jeudi méchant j'ai été pendant
40 ans à la retraite sur deux comme
croient que les jeux s'assagissent
quatre jours par mois le reste plutôt
faites ce que vous voulez vous gagner un
fusil et l'autre la pétanque je suis au
théâtre je voyais mes potes le terrain
vous avez vous avez toujours continuer
oui même en amateur j'ai jamais j'ai
essayé de jamais d'être clément sa meute
est trop à coeur ou même quand j'en
faisais pas japon deux des textes pour
moi donc voilà donc envie d'avoir une
mémoire qui étaient encore à peu près
n'ont guère et qui vous sert à activis a
beau s'y installa vous êtes en tournée
pour avec avec une pièce puis il ya eu
alors puisque puisque la cdc des
humoristes vous avez vous avez fait
aussi vous un one man show avec un petit
je suis encore jeune je détermine la
vraie qui s'appelle je hais les jeunes
oui assez provocateur il très
provocateur même peut-être un peu trop
mais il ya des gens qui ont renoncé à
venir à cause de ça à avignon je vous
rappelle dans les rues qu'en chaise je
sais de flyers comme on dit on s'est
laissé les distributeurs non j'irai pas
avoir ce truc comment ça se fait que
j'ai beau expliquer ses crochets autant
que c'est de l'humour que j'ai gratté
met à dos et tout leur nom viendra pas
voir ça donc ça va vous un petit
problème mais c'est pas grave je me suis
bien marré ça a été écrit par eric
laugérias qui a fait un bon alors il me
fait un très joli texte et je suis très
contente de défendre ça mais c'est très
différent c'est très ccc comment alors
se retrouver seul en scène c'est c'est
très différent
derrière qu'avait avec en ayant fait les
deux je préfère jouer avec d'autres
ah oui c'est sûr
d'abord parce qu'on partage la
responsabilité et puis qu il ya des
soirs où on est plus ou moins bien les
autres vous sont un peu la mise en
éclats à l'énergie l'énergie l'élargir
ou là comment ça va y aller soit on a
vraiment pareil quand on fait un petit
miracle quand même qui se produit quand
ça dépend du nombre de gens à la salle
avec moi ma fille axelle qui était en
one man one woman show elle m'a dit mais
qui est 10 personnes ou 150 ou 300 bas
toi et moi je dis donc nombreux à la
case je fais un quart d'heure de moi je
vais à toute vitesse les gens de chez
moi c'est pas très professionnel mais
quand ça marche si je me bats à morat
j'essaye de donner un maximum
quand je vois que ça prend pas tout de
suite mais c'est pas un trait de
caractère
un non mais c'est vrai je sais ça fait
que vous auriez vous avez encore une
fois la carrière que vous avez été
violée tout à fait gérable mais mais
c'est vrai que peut-être que vous avez
peut-être laissé tomber des choses parce
que je la vis était assez facile ou faut
vous dire j'ai jamais été riche mais
j'ai bien gagné gagner votre vie j'en ai
profité
mes potes les amis les femmes qu'on veut
et puis voilà c'est vrai que j'ai
préféré marais que de bosser toujours
faim de temps en temps voir je
reconstruis fort j'ai jamais vraiment
fait nous disent mince affaire puisque
c'était joli les jeunes ça vous énerve
ça va sûrement sur sas monde meilleur
mais c'est vrai que j'ai une fille et
j'ai la chance d'avoir une fille qui est
encore jeune qui a 18 ans qui vient
d'avoir 18 ans et c'est vrai que
ggp deux grands enfants qui sont
beaucoup plus âgées dont axel et g10 et
baboo coupe lvg dans carrière
télévisuelle je pensais à bon bref
tallec avec elle j'ai été beaucoup plus
présent et c'est vrai qu'on a eu
beaucoup de conversations ou et puis je
me suis aperçu que tout entre août et
nouvelles technologies internet iphone
le tout cas ça m'a rendu dingue
d'où vient le titre parce que temps en
temps je disais nous battent ils
m'arrêtent je hais les jeunes et mon
producteur m'a dit mais tiens voilà
développé mme sarr et puis voilà puis on
a fait un truc assez rigolo non marqué
oui vous faisiez demi quand même non pas
du tout alors quand je crois pas dit non
non l'iphone j'en ai eu à me la piquer
trois semaines après donc j'ai décidé de
ne plus revoir et internet je n'y ai
jamais touché
jamais je suis désolé non mais ça
m'intéresse pas ça ne m'intéresse pas
peut-être peut-être que j'ai réduit
faire l'effort soit certain moment le
mec me dise où il fallait des gens me
disent
donne moi ton mail et gmail avec comment
je fais pour t'envoyer battu le
téléphone c'est moi qui m'en envoie un
courrier me tillie à me voir mais j'ai
pas de mal ça m'intéresse pas alors
quand il ya des choses c'est vrai que
c'est un outil indispensable des choses
des recherches de comme ça ça me
rapproche de ma fille parce qu'elle
n'est fait pour moi je suis avec elle
mais disons le le maniement de l'objet
de l'objet c'est elle qui le fait pas
moins cher possible
au début quand j'ai commencé un jour est
arrivé dans l'adoration mais elle me
voyait je promenais la souris sur ma
main et elle m'a dit mais qu'est ce que
tu fais mais je ne sais pas si je
pensais que c'est comme ça qu'on faisait
donc le débat avec le bus locaux donc
présider le festival d'humour de
rocquencourt on est assez frappé quand
même aujourd'hui vous avez fait par le
nombre et notamment des jeunes et des
jeunes qui volent à distance dans ce
dans ce métier j'aimerais comme si comme
s'il y avait il me semble qu'ils aient
jamais eu et autres d'humoristes entre
guillemets sur scène qu aujourd'hui donc
c'est quand même très compliqué pour eux
pour se faire remarquer pour normes et
c'est déjà quelqu'un qui veut monter sur
scène
il a il a une facilité à faciliter toute
relative à faire ça parce que c'est pas
cher c'est vrai je veux dire monter à
moi de manon le tout seul c'est simple
que ces road jack scène avec très peu
d'accessoires ou même pas du tout pas de
décor de trois lumières bon ça coûte
moins cher commenté une pièce de théâtre
avec cinq six comédiens donc déjà c'est
une facilité puis il ya eu ces frais
faut pas le nier
laurent ruquier qui grâce à son émission
à tout d'un coup offert un tremplin
plein de jeunes et maintenant tous les
jeunes enfin la plupart des jeunes
faisait maurice qui font leurs trousses
ils viennent de chez ruquier quoi ces
espèces de creuser jeudi en venant en
mettant avignon que j'ai fait l'an
dernier à prendre pendant le festival
tous ceux qui cartonnait tous ceux qui
étaient pleins sans arrêt qui profilent
les gens avaient vu c'était les gens de
chez ruquier
la télévision fait beaucoup aussi au
fait que sur oisy ça vous apporte ses
opposants ouais c'est à double tranchant
parce que les gens c'est comme moi en
france on aime bien mettre les gens dans
une case
hélas un mec de télé c'est pas que pour
moi arthur compliqué même même qu est
maintenant
je sais qu'il y en a un autre qui va
c'est je crois que sais je sais pas qui
c'est l'humain les 18 qui si elle se
faire virer de chance de regarder tout
le monde se lance là dessus et pour
l'épauler gens on n'est pas des semaines
mais là on n'est pas légitime
c'est vrai qu'on voit des gens de la
télé un peu partout si aussi colonisent
le truc voilà mais voilà non mais le
problème c'est que il y en a qui ont
fait de la télé qui font ça après vous
c'est vous c'est vous venez de là vous
avez fait de la techno mission jeunes
gens le gentil fils matériel comédien
peut pas dire que les gens se
souviennent vraiment donc nous raconter
ça à oui je regrette de repas offerts
ont fait une grande carrière
mais peut-être que je n'avais pas le
talent qu'on puisse y a un truc sur les
jets jamais le trac je ne sais pas ce
que c'est l'amour entre sur scène rien
je peux je peux faire l'imbécile cinq
minutes avant faire la plus grosse
connerie gens tu fais mon truc plus ou
moins bien et je me rappelle toujours
cette phrase que vous connaissez bien
s'armer de jouer voilà je ne fume pas
les bianchi jamais le trac en me
souviendrai que le talent dont elle me
dit peut-être que je les âges et à
l'autre qu'est-ce que dans l'est dont
les humoristes vous allez voir pour les
spectacles ah oui oui oui je vois pas
tout le temps parce que j'ai aussi pas
mal pris par des activités théâtrales
justement surtout depuis la non là mais
bon j'ai des gens que j'adore moi
j'adore bondues sont plus ou moins
connus artus que j'adore votre mère
j'aimerais j'aimerais jérémy ferrari
lascars gays
là je vous dirais pas qu'ils sont sortis
d'ailleurs bien sûr les paris qu'ils
parcourent julie ferrier paris fériés et
de benoist aussi benoît aime beaucoup
maintenant je vais dès que je peux je
peux y aller j'y vais il ya un genre
d'humour qui est plutôt le veau dans
lequel vous reconnaissez bouaicha c'est
difficile au niveau du rire la salle est
terrible parce que j'ai déjà dit ça une
personne qui s'occupe de festival fait
pour me faire les élans faut ici j'aime
pas la vanne la grosse vanne un peu
d'abord j'aime bien les spectacles qui
traite un peu d'un sujet d'un point a à
un point b ou d'un point un bon allez y
j'aime pas trop le spectacle à sketches
mais ça s'est moins bien ces feux des
personnes refoulées personnages ou alors
il faut être très très bon et comédien
oui et c'est pas c'est pas toujours le
cas il ya souvent des sketchs sont
drôles mais comme le parti jeu et
laisser un peu donc moi j'aime bien les
choses qui vient compte que voilà qu'ils
racontent
ou alors un numéro 2 les mots très très
grinçant par exemple sur timsit qui va
loin
des flics sont des gens comme sa mère et
ferrari qui font loin au 6 juillet on
n'a pas dès le titre de la pièce avec ça
s'appelle coup de foudre c'est une pièce
que de francis joffo qui était un mec a
beaucoup maigri qui a été l'assistant de
poules a pendant longtemps et qui est
une assez jolie pièce qui pas vraiment
un boulevard qui est une pièce un peu
douce amère mais en même temps drôle et
dans mon cas bradent leurs principales
qui s'appelle maurice risch qui est
vraiment très très très très efficace
c'est-à-dire comme qu'on peut se bourrer
parce que moi quand je les lui je me
suis dit j'ai d'ailleurs je me suis un
peu fâché avec l'auteur parce que julie
tapia c'est pas drôle donc mc moi qui
trouvais génial à la lecture après il
n'a passé 7 mondial j'étais nul mais
j'aurais pas dire ça et finalement c'est
lui qui a raison parce que cette pièce
qui au départ à la lecture n'est pas une
pièce où on se marre vraiment quand on
la joue et son public elle ne fonctionne
merveilleusement bien tant mieux merci
infiniment patrice laffont est bon c'est
à val de reuil messieurs je vais être
juste et sévère juste et bon sévère mais
juste merci beaucoup placé